thank you very much and thank you very
much for your continuing support so it's
a great pleasure and honor for us to
welcome Michael Dukakis here at Yale for
this annual lecture governor Dukakis is
presently a colleague of sorts he's a
professor of political science at
Northeastern University so I'm very
pleased by that but of course he's very
widely known for for his political
career that spans a very very long time
in a way one can say he's a living
history of American politics of the last
40 years Michael Stanley Dukakis was
born in Brookline Massachusetts both of
his parents were immigrants from Greece
and he grew up in Boston he studied at
Swarthmore College and then went to
Harvard Law School and after serving in
the military in the US military
he began very early on a stellar
political career he started in 1970 he
started initially in fact in the
nineteen sixties serving in local
positions and then in 1970 he was
nominated as the Massachusetts he was
the nominee for the Massachusetts
Democratic Party for the position of
lieutenant government government of
governor of Massachusetts he didn't win
that election there is a very
interesting nonlinear political career
but then he came back in 1978 in 1974 he
was elected as a governor he was
defeated after the end of his first term
he had to serve under very adverse
economic conditions but then after being
away for four years he was elected and
then he was elected again for a second
term so altogether he served as
three-term governor of Massachusetts
with this interruption in the middle
however the reason he is nationally
known in the United States
because in 1988 he was nominated by the
Democratic Party to be the candidate of
the party in the presidential election
of that year he faced George Bush the
senior and he was defeated in that
election but it's really his
participation in that election that
brought him national attention after
that he finished his service as governor
of Massachusetts and decided not to go
back into active politics his career
since then spans both academic work and
policy work he's been a faculty at
Northeastern University in Boston as I
said in political science and he has
also served in various positions in
policy including most notably on the
board of directors of Amtrak which is
very interesting and he has been also an
observer and commentator of American
politics trying to understand the
various developments in that area and
that's precisely what he's going to talk
to us about tonight I'd like to
highlight by way of connecting myself to
him two moments and two memories which
come together in the summer of 1988 this
was when having won a Fulbright
scholarship as an undergraduate in
Greece I came to study in the United
States I was accepted at the University
of Chicago as a PhD student I had never
been in the United States before that
was my first time and Fulbright actually
sent me to California at the University
of California Davis for an orientation
program so I arrived in Sacramento never
having been in the United States before
and of course that was the summer of
1988 presidential campaign
I remember that campaign very very
vividly because it was the first major
political event I witnessed in the in
the United States and one of the things
that I remember at the time which was
quite shocking was the extent to which
Michael Dukakis had to face a very
negative campaign from the Republican
side in hindsight we know that that was
the beginning of a turn
in American politics in which what we
may describe as nasty polarizing
political campaigning gained a lot of
traction in the fact that it was
successful that it worked with the
Republicans at the time certainly gave
that new mix of policy of political
strategies a lot of traction in American
politics for worse however the thing
that is really striking of course is
when we look back at those times what
appears to have been extremely negative
and very nasty pales in comparison to
what we're experiencing today and I'd be
very interested to hear governor Dukakis
his thoughts about that evolution its
causes potential consequences the second
thing that I would like to mention is
that for me arriving in the United
States for the first time at that
particular juncture I remember very
vividly every time I was interacting
with an American they would ask me where
I'm from I would say from Greece and
then they would say Michael Dukakis and
and for me that was an incredibly
welcoming reaction for a variety of
reasons first of all because I felt that
being Greek was not something trivial in
fact a person from my homeland was
presidential candidate Angele the next
president of the United States the
second thing was that it gave me the
feeling that this was a country that
could turn the son of immigrants into a
president and therefore it gave me a
sense that this could be a home this was
a welcoming country diverse country that
gave a lot of opportunities to the
people who came to the shore to its
Shore and so I am very grateful and very
glad after 30 years that was in 1988 to
take this opportunity to thank you for
making me so welcome when I arrived from
the first time in the United States so
I'm very happy to welcome you tonight
here for this annual lecture thanks for
coming
[Applause]
this will be less a lecture and more I
hope an informal and interesting
discussion which is why the way I tried
to teach anyway so I couldn't deliver a
lecture from a script if I if I tried
but I'm glad that I made you welcome
even if I wasn't conscious about it
the support I got from the Greek
community during that election was
extraordinary and some of you are here
and I'm very grateful to all of you who
are part of this I'm not sure I'm gonna
be able to do to say anything definitive
tonight about how we try to deal with
our problems in a bipartisan way but
it's very interesting I just had my 84th
birthday I feel like a million bucks and
my dear mother who came here at the age
of nine with her family and settled in
Haverhill Massachusetts shoe town in
those days and so far as we can
determine was the first Greek young
woman ever to go away to college unless
courted in the history of the United
States never happened before thanks to
an elementary school principal named
Stanley gray if you want to know why my
middle name is Stanley and not my
father's which is a great tradition as
most of you know it's because my mother
wanted one of her sons to carry that
name and he became a second father to
her her father was a guy who had great
respect for educators and mr. gray was
very very important person in the family
life and so this little Greek girl not
only finished high school itself unusual
but went away to Bates College
underscored it never happened before and
graduated Phi Beta Kappa 1925 she was
born and grew up in Latin my dad whose
people were from et leaning from lesbos
actually grew up in a predominantly
Greek town in western Turkey it was
called either Dmitri the grief column
meaty mature Scala dead German town of
about 12,000 75% Greek at the time and
he was born in 1896 and when he was
fifteen in 1912 and I don't know if this
had anything to do with the young turk
movement which was obviously beginning
to become very important in Turkey but
the age of 15 he decided want to come
the United States to get an education
now as many of you know in those days
young Greeks didn't come here to get an
education on the most part they came
here to get a job but this 15 year old
decided he want to come here again
education he had two brothers who were
working in the textile mills and Lowell
and Lawrence didn't speak a word of
English didn't have a nickel in his
pocket and twelve years laters you've
just heard my dad graduated from Harvard
Medical School how he did it I have no
idea folks worked in the mills worked in
restaurants went to night school went to
Boston University for a year itself very
unusual and met another Greek the guy
names Arif he's somehow convinced him
that the two of them ought to become
doctors those days I didn't eat it was
two years of free medical and somehow
they ended up at Bates now this is long
before my mother was there it had no
connection to do one year of pre-medical
he did all their science stuff and he
wanted to go to Harvard Medical School
and he was put on the waiting list it
was very very disappointed and he ended
up at Dartmouth which in those days was
a two-year medical school from which you
transferred to some other medical school
and with a very heavy heart he went up
to Hanover they showed in his room said
this was Daniel Webster's room my father
I'm gonna - we knew who Daniel Webster
wasn't any event he didn't care and a
week later he got a telegram from his
mother family have settled in Lowell
saying come home Harvard Medical that's
a bidded you did four years of medical
school internships residences and
practice medicine for 52 years at 4:54
Huntington Avenue for those of you from
with geography lesson right across the
Museum of Fine Arts interestingly enough
that apartment building is it was at
that time and where my parents spent the
first three years of their married life
it's now Burstein Holland Northeastern
University wherever in teaching for 26
years so when people say to me up a
voice then you know grace I say a
meeting you know she me because he got
these yummy ladies sales game he may he
be rotties because my maternal
grandparents came from a little village
called visa hoodie in in a Paris and
then the folks in Corfu decided to make
me an honorary citizen so I added a
fifth daughter
you may call for your teas but it's a
great heterogeneity heritage thanks to
my guy on my father's side didn't speak
a word of English and lipless for the
first seven years of our of my life
I grew up bilingual you know I think I
speak pretty good
seven-year-old Greek but I as I said the
folks when we were meeting when I go to
Greece and Kitty and I try to go there
every once every three years or so and
they put me on television I say to them
I need to come Mooney poorly apply then
Alexei wouldn't econ Costolo
so they have to put me in English with
subtitles so that is fortunately I fell
in love with a wonderful woman who's
with us tonight and in her own right has
done extraordinary advocacy particularly
the field of mental health and refugees
and immigrants worked as a social worker
professionally with refugees and
immigrants and I always introduce her as
the best looking Medicare recipient in
America she is but she's here with us
tonight Kitty Dukakis
she's about to have her 81st birthday so
we're gonna have a big celebration Katie
was one the day after Christmas which is
always a difficult thing and now we
celebrate Christmas with our son and his
family in Boston and we our daughters
are in Denver and San Francisco and each
you have a couple of kids so they
swapped birthday celebrations and then
we dragged ourselves off to UCLA for the
winter quarter it's a terrible burden
but somebody's got to do it and and
we've had a really remarkable thing and
they are just beginning a Hellenic
studies program there and I hope I'm
gonna be at least in my three months
involved with that so what you folks
have done here really is a mom model for
us and the Greek community and in Los
Angeles very enthusiastic about about
the new Atlantic Studies program at UCLA
they've been very generous and very
supportive and and we're looking forward
to it so what about bipartisanship was
America a kind of center of
bipartisanship over the course of its
political career the answer to that
question is absolutely not
yeah that campaign in 88 where I should
have done a much better job of feeling
that at TACC campaign that I did was
pretty nasty and I did a terrible job of
responding to it and I had been through
some very tough negative campaigns in my
gubernatorial races so it wasn't as if
this was a new phenomenon but I made
what turned out to be a pretty dumb
decision and that was that I was not
going to respond to thee to the attack
impact and one of my closest colleagues
among the nation's governors was Mario
Cuomo a guy I admired enormously and
when we were talking about the race
initially he said look forget about that
don't worry about this attack stuff just
ignore it
it's not gonna it's not going to affect
anything we were campaigning together
four days before the election in
November of 88 in Queens he turned to me
says the worst advice I ever gave you
but
responded to it because I think like
Mario were positive people were not
interested in acting like a couple of
kids in a sandbox only sanded each other
and we just turned out to be the wrong
strategy which was very vulnerable the
most liberal furlough program in America
was the Reagan Bush furlough program in
the federal prison system they were
furling people for 45 days one of the
FIR Louise when I were today young
pregnant mother in the southwest all
that kinda stuff
I never said that well you don't respond
to that kind of stuff folks it's gonna
take its toll so I apologize to wall Ave
I used to say if I'd beaten Bush one you
never heard of Bush two because I
thought Bush two was the worst president
I'd ever lived under until this this guy
came along more on that later
and it is not true that the United
States has been a haven of bipartisan
politics the politics of this country
immediately after the declaration of
independence and the ratification of the
Constitution were brutal and even the
press made no pretense of being
objective
in fact when Jefferson left the
presidency after eight years he said
something about finally being able to
get the jackals of the press office back
or words to that effect it was brutal it
was very tough and every once in while
these days people say to me well have
you ever seen it this bad and I say to
them did you see the movie Lincoln I
mean that was bad American politics have
been rough and in many cases quite
partisan partisan and we've gone through
some very very difficult periods I don't
know how many of you familiar with what
happened in this country right after
World War one when we had domestic
terrorism far in excess of anything that
we've ever experienced in this kind
what what's going on I mean you know
what was going on at that time
especially in major northeastern cities
terrorists many of them anarchists were
blowing up cities regularly in fact one
of them blew up the home of the Attorney
General this guy Palma who subsequently
wants the so called Palmer Raids and was
a graduate of Swarthmore College can't
believe it a graduate of a Quaker
institution being involved in this kind
of thing and in point of fact Sacco and
Vanzetti went to chip went to the one of
the Elector cher folks not because they
committed that crime they didn't but
because they were Italian immigrants and
they happened to be anarchists now they
weren't violent anarchists they had
never engaged in any violent activity
but there isn't any question those folks
were convicted because they were
southern Europeans tend so on and so
forth and and those Palmer raids were a
response to regular terrorist attacks in
major American cities especially east of
the Mississippi I'm trying to think of
maybe a timer to when the United States
was a haven for bipartisan activity and
there's no question that we've had some
of those situations but I was at
Swarthmore from 1951 to 1955 that's when
a guy when you named Joseph R McCarthy
was doing his thing it was a terrible
time folks and McCarthy had his
supporters so I'm at Swarthmore and this
Greek kid at a Quaker College I had
never been out of New England I didn't
know a Quaker from a shaker I had no
idea what this is all about but I knew
it was pretty good school I want to get
out of New England and I had thought
about going to beit's my brother was
there but he said you know you like
cities so why don't you take a look at
Swarthmore I said isn't that a girl's
fool he said though that's Skidmore I
mean that's how much we know but it was
these were four very important years
and I got quite active politically and
within six weeks after I graduated in
1955 I was drafted in the United States
Army and showed up at the Fargo building
in Boston with 30 other characters and
we got on a train and we went to Fort
Dix New Jersey for our first eight weeks
of basic training three weeks three days
after we got there three days after we
got there we had what passed for a
personnel interview five minutes
in front of another draftee it was a
personnel specialist so-called who
decided what you would do for the next
two years
except my guy had a file on mate
this is in pre-computer America with
every single political activity I'd ever
engage in a sophomore college so the
interview went something like this so I
see you ran a fundraising drives the
American Civil Liberties Union while
you're on the sophomore campus yeah as a
matter of fact I did and you were the
chairman of students for democratic
action which was a student wing of the a
DA the Liberal Democratic organization
by the way I succeeded in that capacity
of Swarthmore by a guy named Carl Levin
who just finished 18 years in the United
States Senate from Michigan
I said yeah as a matter of fact I was
and we went through this thing now I was
a little concerned folks because I knew
people who had been drafted and they'd
been held for months and in some cases
discharged dishonorably or other than
honorably because of some organization
that they had joined when they're in
high school one of them happened to be a
dear friend of mine who had joined
something called the United world
Federalist was it left it wasn't right
it was basically for a strong UN and
that guy spent three or four months
before his father was able to get a hold
of Paul Douglas and Dick Neuberger and
both United States senators who managed
to make it possible for him to serve the
military and then went to medical school
and there's been a doctor to community
health center for many many years in
Boston and I'm not sure I decided at the
time I wanted to go into politics
professionally but it's kind of the back
of my head and I wasn't interested in
starting my political career with
another than honorable discharge
needless to say anyway
fortunately the guy didn't recommend
that and sent me to Korea which was okay
how do you think the government got that
information on this Greek kid from
Boston who had just spent four years at
a small college outside of Philadelphia
ten years later we discovered that the
FBI had a tap of a Swarthmore
switchboard was recording every single
phone call must be dead
switchboard and apparently had somebody
that you and I were paying taking notes
to come up with files on that guy it was
a terrible terrible period folks and
there were no neutrals you really the
probe McCarthy or Andy McCarthy Vietnam
was worse if there at least some of you
old enough to remember during that
period it was families were divided
friends were divided there was nothing
bipartisan about that war so we've been
here before now the fact that we have
somebody in the White House who's
charitably what a little strange
obviously colors.this and when I was at
Swarthmore I don't know how many
political scientists we have in the room
there was a guy at Wesleyan named shot
Schneider any folks who were shot
Snyder's then they mean anything to any
of you one personal banker one - yeah
shot Schneider was arguing that the
United States and its politics weren't
partisan enough you had Liberal
Democrats and conservative Democrats in
the South who pretty much controlled the
Congress as a result of any seniority
and they never voted together you had
conservative Republicans and liberal
Republicans a lot of especially in the
Northeast
folks that I worked with very closely
good people she had the same values and
so on and so forth but what did it mean
to be a Republican what did it mean to
be a Democrat when you had conservatives
and liberals in the same party shot
Snyder are
very forcefully there was time to turn
the parties into organizations it stood
for something and we did it
and now we're very under self but shot
Snyder's thesis and it's gone the shot
Snyder thesis is what that what's the
point of going in and voting Democratic
or republican if you don't know what's
gonna happen when it's all over and
remember the conservative Democrats were
largely from the south and blatantly
segregationist and racist and one of the
great partisan battles in this country
was the civil rights revolution in which
we finally decided that at least we hope
we decided that color of somebody's skin
was not something that I didn't put that
person a horribly inferior position and
we're still working at it still working
at it even as this country gets browner
burner and apparently that's bothering
some folks cuz Charlotte's filled no I
don't think we should take it overly
seriously but Charlotte phil was a
reflection of the fact that there are
people out there who who apparently have
very very my opinion dangerous and
biased opinions and they were obviously
reflected to some extent and in this guy
that's currently in the White House all
this by way of background we've gone
through lots and lots of partisan
battles in this country the question is
what do we do about it now and the short
answer to it as far as I'm concerned is
I'm not sure now at the state and local
level at least in my experience there's
much less partisanship its partisan and
there are ideological differences but
there must be some reason why the
nation's mayor's most of Democrats with
some Republicans seem to come together
around a common agenda and I think it's
because they're all facing the same
kinds of problems some of my closest
colleagues in the National gun
Association Dan Evans from Washington
who taught me a lot as a rookie governor
thoughtful progressive and more than
willing to reach out to us young guys
had just showed up in the organization
and extremely helpful there was at the
time a new generation of young white
democratic governors in the south who
were Pro civil rights let me tell you
folks that took a lot of guts who were
they well it started with a guy named
Bill winter in Mississippi a remarkable
guy still going strong at 93 and then
there were guys like Clinton Bob Graham
and Florida dick Riley who I just talked
to the other day in South Carolina a
wonderful guy but Lamar Alexander a
Republican who were pro civil rights and
got themselves elected in the south but
that whole struggle which continues was
not fun folks and in point of fact the
civil rights revolution itself in many
cases was violent people wants their
lives and and the politics around race
were brutal so what do we do about this
well here's what I teach my kids as for
having that north-eastern these days and
I spent a lot of time talking about how
you try to build consensus in politics
and get things done because you can't
get things done in politics without
building consensus it took me 20 years
to figure that out and a defeat for
re-election the first time to kind of
wake up to this first now he does defeat
so vo a little bit but it makes you a
much better listener I was a pretty good
talker when I went into politics I
wasn't a very good listener
and after being defeated for reelection
that first time I started
listening to people more and I
discovered two things first listening is
less tiring than talking and secondly
you learn stuff and after about 20 years
of this business I finally began to get
the hang of it so what do I teach my
students these days about trying to
build consensus first that you go out
and identify all of the key people I
hate this word stakeholder because
nobody knows what it means but yeah I
call them key players and you bring them
together in the form of a working group
now you've got to keep it reasonably
reasonably sized a working group of whom
of people interested in the issue many
of whom can't stand each other's guts
when the process begins and it's
remarkable what happens folks when you
bring people together especially if
you're a prominent office holder sit
them down with good staff who
understands how to do this and begin to
go to work and see if you can identify
agreement around common problems and I
want to talk about this in the context
of health care in this country which has
been occupying us for a long time
we're the only advanced industrialized
nation in the world that does not
provide comprehensive health care for
all of its people and as you can see
from this I'll get to the tax bill in a
second which i think is the most
unbelievable piece of legislation I've
ever seen in my life but and and seeks
to weaken the Affordable Care Act again
if you want to take a poll tomorrow
among the American people and ask them
should working Americans and their
families have decent affordable health
care what do you think the numbers look
like
93% say yes and the other seven have
them thought about serious I'm serious
and the vast majority of uninsured
people in this country are working on
working families they're not loafing
they're not sitting around they're not
on public assistance we're on welfare
you get medicaid he's a working
Americans no health care and when they
get so sick that they can't stand up
they end up in the emergency room and
we're all pampered in the form of
increased premiums and increased taxes
93% say yes now I was a fan of Barack
Obama's I want to talk a little bit
about the foreign policy side of this
bipartisanship and I and he worked very
hard in this but he never really in this
case delivered a message which i think
and as a guy that put up universal
health care bill through his state
legislature did constantly talking about
working Americans and their families not
having decent affordable health care
Americans like people will work and
they're appalled by the notion that
working Americans their families can't
have decent affordable health care so
this very broad agreement across this
country about that and so the
interesting question is why is it become
so partisan an issue I'm not gonna
criticize the former president who got
elected twice I couldn't even get it
once I got a lot of respect for him
politically in otherwise but I do think
that message a this is about working
Americans this is about working
Americans they have families would have
resonated more than we're gonna get rid
of pre-existing conditions and he can
keep the kids on the policy until
they're 26 it seemed to me that was the
central message which by the way neither
the administration nor the Democrats in
Congress seemed to focus on and I
finally got so upset at one point that I
called the White House I don't do this
very often of course these days I don't
do it at all but back in husband and I
talked to the young woman who was
handling press for the on the health
care bill and I said to her hey look
I've got a great respect for your boss I
mean he got elected twice I couldn't
even collect it once but I did put a
universal health care bill through my
legislature and I said it must have had
200 press events
and there was always a working personal
working family next to me at that podium
talking about what it was like to try to
live and work of sports yourself and
your family without decent health
insurance and she said to me what's your
source for that I said 85% of the
uninsured bhima's country a working
members working family she said what's
your source for that I said it's the
Census Bureau worse for you boss
so about two days later President Obama
mentioned working people for the first
time of discussion health care and she
called me and said you see what the
president said I said yeah he's got to
say it 20 times a day and so does the
Congress didn't happen could we have
gotten bipartisan support of a health
care bill that emphasizes the importance
of providing health care to working
folks and their families don't know
don't know but that wasn't the central
theme unfortunately and message is
important folks that's another lesson
you learn from getting your head handed
to you in your first run for reelection
I don't know folks at this point that
it's possible to somehow get back to
that day when we had notwithstanding
professor shot Schneider liberal or
progressive or whatever you want to call
him moderate Republicans and Democrats
who who managed to get some stuff done
could Medicare today pass this Congress
I doubt it very much I doubt it very
much this tax bill I'm sorry I'm the son
of Greek immigrants if I heard the words
he called Omiya mija do you call no Mimi
got it once I heard him a thousand times
Greeks wastes nothing right worth 50 we
economize does anybody know what the
current US budget deficit is just this
year what is it
seven hundred billion dollars and we're
close to full employment there were
better economists in this room that I am
I'm not an economist but I'm sorry we're
close to full employment but this time
we ought to have a surplus a guy named
Clinton you remember him in his last
State of the State address State of the
Union address proposed a plan which he
said credibly would reduce and eliminate
the national debt in ten to twelve years
that was at a time when we had a surplus
of a quarter of a trillion dollars first
time that had happened in 50 years under
a democratic administration and the
Republicans at the time in Congress
wanted a tax cut we had full employment
in those days and I think the economists
will agree that you don't cut taxes when
you have full employment you got to
start worrying about inflation a few
other things and when the pollsters went
out and asked the American people this
was in the year 2000 whether they were
for the president's plan or they wanted
a tax cut they said forget about the tax
cut by two-to-one do what the
president's talking about what was he
talking about putting money away for
Social Security 2035 anticipating
contingencies doing the kinds of stuff
that responsible people tend to do under
these circumstances why are we talking
about a tax cut when we have a budget
deficit of 700 billion dollars and with
close to full employment this is
absolutely insane folks I'm sorry I mean
forget about the bill itself which is
you know back to giving tax cuts to the
wealthy and trickle-down economics
didn't work the first time we're gonna
try it again
but I'm sorry I mean how do you if you
if you're and frankly I'm not hearing a
lot about the budget deficit from the
Democrats they don't like the tax cut
they think it ought to be for the middle
class I'm sorry you know most of us the
middle class
there's no room at this point my
judgment in American economic policy for
a tax cut for the middle class we've got
to get this budget deficit eliminate it
and start running some surpluses if
we're at full of employment otherwise
sorry to say this we're gonna start
looking more like Greece and its
troubles I mean this this budget this
this build is gonna give us a current an
operating deficit of a trillion and a
half dollars any of you know what we're
spending on debt service right now every
year just to pay the interest on 20
trillion dollars in debt remember the
clinton plan we've eliminated it in fact
at the time Alan Greenspan was the
chairman of the Federal Reserve and he
he wasn't against it but he was troubled
he said well if you don't have some debt
how can the Fed works the Clinton said
well give you you know half a trillion
dollars in debt well so you can do your
thing
why are we spending just to service the
national debt every year
anybody know 500 billion dollars half a
trillion dollars just for interest on
this debt that we piled up you go to a
trillion and a half folks and about a
third of the federal budget is going to
be paying interest I think that's very
bad policy and I'm not sure how given
what appears to be now virtual unanimity
in the part of the Republicans in the
Senate and a substantial majority in the
house I don't know how you figure that
one out on a bipartisan basis I mean
sure the Democrats have been talking
more about fiscal responsibility which
unfortunately my party doesn't do as
much as it should should we've been
trying to explain to the American people
that that this is serious and very
flawed economic policy I'm not sure how
one solves that problem on a bipartisan
basis if 52 Republican senators now if
kind of
lined up for this and this was the party
in which to its credit used to talk
about fiscal responsibility until Dick
Cheney came along and said Reagan proved
that deficits don't matter I'm here to
tell you I think deficits matter it's
not that you don't want to run them from
time to time especially if you're in
deep trouble economically but if you
have a trillion and a half dollar debt
folks and we go into another recession
you tell me where we're gonna find the
resources to get out of that one well
this is just crazy so what's the answer
to all of this you look for at least
some issues where you can find common
ground
I may be an optimist I am an optimist
you can't be in politics and be a
definite pessimist you don't think that
good people working together can make a
difference in the lives of their fellow
citizens and don't go into politics but
I think there were some issues and I
think there was an opportunity there
incidentally you all know that Richard
Nixon proposed a very good health care
plan right any of you anybody hold
enough to remember that except me wasn't
Universal Medicare but it was a
comprehensive universal plan in which
employers and employees would have to
contribute to health care at the
workplace all of them without exception
75 percent employer 25 percent employee
with a somewhat expanded Medicaid
program for people that were temporarily
unemployed that was a Nixon plan if Ted
Kennedy were here today to tell you the
worst political mistake he ever made was
in not supporting that plan because with
Kennedy's support in the sport of Labor
and the Liberals who have gone through
Congress life like enough knife through
butter
and it wasn't until they tried to get
universal Medicare and couldn't that
they find decided to sit down with
Nixon's people and a young assistant
secretary named Stuart Allman who's been
teaching at Brandeis for many many years
and came up with a plan which would have
through Congress except for something
called Watergate
and once watergate hit and Nixon's
presidency was destroyed that was the
end of the Nixon plan one state in the
United States decided to pass a state
version of the Nixon plan what state was
that not Massachusetts that came later
state of Hawaii little Hawaii out there
I remember when Dan Quayle was asked
about the Hawaiian health care plan and
you know like most folks in Washington
he had never heard of the Hawaiian
health care plan but it was a state
version of the Nixon plan and it's been
operating Hawaii since 1975 virtually
universal coverage some of the best
health hub health outcomes in America a
little Hawaii nobody knows about it
nobody cares about in Washington for
reasons I don't understand but the Nixon
plan would have been an excellent health
plan and it would have cover everybody
and we wouldn't be going through this
crazy debate could we get back to that
with this Congress support the Nixon
plan No why not why not because it has
an employer and an employee mandate but
you can't have universal health care
folks unless all of us are required to
contribute something now when it comes
to folks at a 65 and older we're
fortunate in the 60s we passed Medicare
does it include a mandate course it
includes a mandate you're paying a piece
of your wage every time you get it for
Social Security and Medicare right and
employers have to do the same what
Medicare goes through this Congress I
kind of doubt it
are there opportunities for bipartisan
cooperation yes but in some cases and I
want to conclude with this that may be
dangerous I don't know how you folks
feel about American foreign policy these
days I'm very upset about it and I'm
upset about it under both Republican and
Democratic presidents
because if this country could not be the
world's policeman with rare exceptions
our military intervention since World
War two have been disastrous and if we
don't get serious about building an
international framework for resolving
international differences and I'm
serious about this I'm not a romantic
about the you and I just think you know
pathy my math email right well my
favorite Greek sayings right things
happen you're supposed to learn from
them
I don't see how you can look at what's
happened since World War two and not
conclude that that this world of ours
needs strong international organization
in which the United States participates
actively and not just to deal with
problems in North Korea which were
resolved toward the end of the Clinton
administration you know with a plan that
the North Koreans bought into before
they had nukes and unfortunately was
essentially torpedoed by the Bush
administration that followed but the
deal with climate change I mean the very
existence of the planet and other
regional disputes that will flare up
from time to time so in that sense this
kind of bipartisan support for a u.s.
role which seems to me to be anything
but a success these days and in fact is
causing more problems not fewer doesn't
strike me as being a good bipartisan
solution I want to know where the people
in my party are who are concerned about
this or a mic kind of an outlier who is
in his old age getting crazy ideas I
don't think so folks I don't think so so
here's a place not where we want people
to be baldly partisan but it's time for
some debate over American foreign policy
and American defense policy which among
other things is now in the process of
spending a trillion dollars to modernize
our nuclear arsenal and that was the
product of the Obama administration now
of course enthusiastically supported by
the new guy in the white house maybe you
think we ought to be spending a trillion
dollars to modernize a nuclear arsenal I
think we ought to be working our heads
off to eliminate nuclear weapons and in
that respect and and that on that issue
Henry Kissinger agrees with me anyway
lots of things going on out there and I
want to stop at this point and open up
things for discussion and feel free to
be as critical as you want because
that's one of the things the Greeks
brought to society the idea of debate
discussion so forth but let me just say
a word or two if I can quickly to the
young people that are here I'm a little
concerned these days I'm not seeing
enough young Greek Americans getting
actively involved in politics there was
a time several years ago when John Brad
amis and Paul sarbanes and myself and a
bunch of others were were doing things
and I hope inspiring young Greeks to go
into it I'm not seeing enough of that
these days folks and let me say this
when Pericles talked about citizenship
in Athens and what the obligation of
citizens to be deeply and actively
involved in the political process and
and when he criticized Athenians who
were not doing that that's a belief that
I share and have been inspired by for a
long time there's nothing like being a
public service and being in a position
where you can make a difference in the
lives of your fellow citizens and kini
and I have had the great good fortune to
be able to do that all of our lives and
with one exception the fact that I never
made it to let's go eagle it's been an
incredible ride and we're still at it my
mother used to say that if you want to
live a long life pick your parents
carefully
she lived till she was a hundred and
Kitty's dad was conducting the Boston
Pops when he was 94 so we're planning to
stick around for a while but I want to
see more and more and more young Greek
Americans getting involved in politics
and I hope you'll do that and if there's
anything I can do to be helpful just
calling me and I'm serious because like
nothing more to be in a position where I
can provide you with whatever guidance I
can when it comes to this kind of thing
okay I'm gonna stop at this point we've
got some time questions comments
reactions criticism fire away who's
first
who wants to start this discussion go
ahead yeah yeah well it would have been
worse on the other hand having
experienced the social media and what it
does and doesn't do obviously we would
have been ready for it and equipped to
go at it now having said that the
challenge there's a challenge here folks
when you're running for office and
somebody's coming at you with this stuff
and I had a very rough fight when I lost
for reelection the first time and came
back on one the second time those were
not lovely peaceful campaigns either one
of them how do you blunt the attacks
without turning itself into an attacker
and then about two weeks people say were
fed up with both of these guys now I was
able to do that successfully because we
didn't have social media in 1982 when I
ran against this guy King with a second
time and beat him but it wasn't a nice
campaign fortunately for me he had run a
pretty sleazy administration and he was
coming at me because in my first term I
had signed the biggest tax increase in
Massachusetts history because the state
was broke I don't know who it was
I wasn't jeez and came up with his idea
but in any event we came back at him by
saying well he may not have raised your
taxes but you're paying a huge
corruption tax as a result of this guy
and it seemed to work and at the same
time people I think thought I was
justified in doing that but that's it's
a fine line that you draw here between
you know getting into the muck so you're
just as bad as the other guy and trying
to maintain some standards in some
integrity while well blunting these
attacks but to go back to your question
I mean in this era you got to be ready
for that stuff all the time all the time
who's next yeah not getting the message
across but the polling shows that the
people don't like the tax plan they get
it it's the politicians who don't seem
to care that we don't like it well some
of them like it because they're voting
for it like 52 of them apparently
well 52 politicians like them are they
listening their constituents has as the
Democratic might have done an effective
job of explaining what's in this plan
I'm not sure we have have we pointed out
to people that were currently running a
deficit of 700 billion dollars it's
gonna increase the national debt by
another 700 billion dollars I'm not
hearing that are you I don't think
people nobody's talking about the
national fiscal state of affairs here
nobody it's all a question of as I said
it's all a question of what tax cut do
you like Democrats say well a lot to be
for the middle class oh sorry with all
due respect the middle class we're all
middle class aren't we most of us
there's no room for a tax cut at this
point we got to get that deficit out of
there and fast before we hit another
recession and then have no physical
fiscal flexibility look one of the
reasons we were able to get out of the
Great Recession folks was because there
was some fiscal flexibility there
although Bush had squandered the surplus
and got us into a war that's gonna cost
us retuning treat three trillion dollars
don't going on by the way but you know I
just sorry I'm being this is this is
this is economic craziness and we're not
hearing enough about just how crazy it
is so we'll see what happens I mean
there we are it's gonna be let me tell
you if we we start running deficits
return and a half dollars we've got very
tough times ahead in my opinion and we
lose the ability to respond when in fact
the economy
get soft
who's next yes yes ma'am
grab that mic yes we can hear I think
the American people would be more than
happy to pay have higher taxes if they
got something back from those taxes if
they had health insurance he had free
education because the Danes the Swedes
and Norwegians and a lot of other people
in this world even outside of
Scandinavia right and then we have to
stop these wars yeah
they're constantly aren't yeah we have a
hundred and fifty bases all over the
world we have this unbelievable 830 837
American bases in 150 countries that's
what we got out there 837 last count
maybe it's changed a little bit I agree
with you 837 American bases in hundred
fifty countries what are they doing out
there what are we doing out there
doesn't seem to me it's contributing to
world peace and stability and those
kinds of things and a lot of our
resources going there and we spend a
seven hundred billion dollars in the
military this year that can't go for
health care and a at least low cost
University educated college education
for kids and all the kinds of things
that I think most Americans would
support so it's it's it's centered
central to our trying to get back get
back on track and achieve some degree a
balance between what's going on well but
part of the political process ought to
be to help people get informed yeah go
ahead
how do we get more infrastructure would
you be willing to run a deficit to get
more infrastructure or could you look
I'm a big train man I don't think that's
a secret Randy I was the guy that led
the fight to kill the so called master
highway plant at Metropolitan Boston
which would have paved over the city of
Boston I kid you not I mean destroyed
the city in my opinion it was a long
tenure fight and then thanks to a
sainted man named Thomas P O'Neill jr.
who we know his tip we managed to change
federal law so that all that highway
money could go into public
transportation if the state or the city
wanted and we took full advantage of
that and as a result we invested three
billion dollars of federal highway
dollars in the Boston transit system now
it's got some management problems these
days but I think we can agree that bus
and Scott at what at least potentially
ought to be the best public
transportation system in there in the
country and it's done wonders for the
City of Boston Boston today is thriving
because we kill that damn highway
planning and use the money for something
else when Barack Obama first became
president he recommended and proposed
ten billion dollars a year to go into a
national rail passenger rail system ten
billion dollars and that's just a
rounding error the Democratic Congress
approved it first year and it was killed
ever since although there are some
Republicans in the Congress who think
that the national rail passenger system
makes sense and that's an area where I
think we could get some bipartisan
agreement but the money's there folks
providing we're not throwing about the
window on all this military stuff 837
American bases in 150 countries and now
we're going to spend a trillion dollars
to modernize
nuclear arsenal doesn't make any sense
to me I don't think we have to raise
taxes to do this we have to make some
judicious cuts in the military budget
and put it into domestic rail which by
the way will not be unhelpful from a
national security standpoint among other
things who's next
yeah you look at a lot of federal races
now it's coming down to a question of
whether or not government is a good
whether it's doing good for the people
or not a lot of conservatives are
running on a platform essentially of
let's eviscerate government the head of
the new head of the federal Consumer
Protection Bureau Mick Mulvaney has
called it an egregious insult to
democracy the the head of the department
was energy energy proposed getting rid
of the Department of Energy when he was
running for the Republican nomination
you're the president and from my
experience people who identifies liberal
progressive Democrat everyone affirm it
generally generally believed a
government to be a good thing that does
good things for the citizens and the and
the country I'm just wondering how you
think you can bridge that divide you
identify a problem that needs a solution
focus on the left left to generally say
we can use government to solve that
problem folks on the right man say
generally let's get government out of it
let private industry tackle that I'm
just curious how your name can bridge
that seemingly critical divide yep I
don't think the argument that government
is either too small or too big is
particularly convincing people ask them
whether or not they want to repeal
Medicare what do you think the numbers
will look like on that one ask I mean
ask them that whether not they want to
go into another Great Recession and
whether or not the government has some
responsibility to do something about
that asking whether or not they want
good schools for their kids and tuition
somewhat less than was it cost to go to
Yale these days what is it
almost selling we have a wonderful
grandson we've got a flock of grandkids
one of them's just started Yale he
started at Tufts 65,000 bucks I paid
$1,100
for room board and tuition that's what's
more College in the 50s now very kind of
a see who can tell you what the
inflation factor ought to be but it
didn't go from 1,100 to 65,000 right
don't ask him whether or not they think
government is too big or too small ask
him whether or not they think these
government-sponsored financed efforts
are important to them why is it that in
so-called red states and I hope the
Democratic Party will stop buying into
this red blue narrative one of the worst
things we've ever done
you know you're right off half the
country from the beginning that's nuts
but you know if you ask and there have
been a number of referenda raising the
minimum wage in so-called red states
they pass with decisive majorities how
come because most of the folks out there
that are voting are middle class
Americans working trying to support
themselves their families with a decent
life their incomes haven't gone up much
at all in fact I think 60% of the
American people of making less in real
terms today and they were twenty years
ago then I gotta tell you they don't
want the government to act they may they
may be frustrated the governor's not
acting in ways that they think it should
act but I don't buy this notion that the
vast majority of Americans of a small
government or medium-sized government or
anything else I think they're interested
in the services that government can
provide to make their lives better and
the lives of their kids and grandkids
better and if you put it in those terms
I mean where are they in this tax cut
they were against it why cuz it's a rich
man's tax cut and that doesn't help them
and it doesn't make a hell of a lot of
sense economically either so I don't
think that's the issue the question is
how do you focus now look this has not
been a good year for the Republican
Party I think we can agree I mean
they're torn apart their each other's
throats dissent
thing I don't know what they can do with
this guy in Alabama get selected are
they gonna refuse to seat him and so on
and so forth if the Democratic Party
doesn't clean their clock in the
congressional elections next year then
there's something wrong with us but it's
got to be a 50-state 185,000 precinct
campaign and I'm serious about this I'm
a huge believer in precinct based
organizing what does that mean a
precinct captain six block capitals
every precinct in the country do you
think 185 thousand precincts in a
country was friends 20 million people
you think the Democratic Party ought to
be able to recruit 185 thousand precinct
captains I would hope so
and I don't care what's your time what
state red blue or otherwise I mean you
know this is the kind of thing that this
party of mine isn't doing didn't do if
we had done it Donald Trump would be
history we didn't do it we didn't do it
and I've seen it work so many times
Elizabeth Warren never would have been
elected the United States Senate she
hadn't had a precinct akes organization
with a precinct captain every one of the
2157 precincts in Massachusetts and
Kitty 9 will take a little bit of credit
for that because she sat down with us
early on so he got the Dukakis speech
right 2107 precinct the 2001 of visiting
briefs in campus each and we could six
block cabins their job is to make
personal contact on an ongoing basis
with every single voting hustle she did
it the polls five days before the
election said the race was tied or Brown
was a little ahead she beat him by 9
percentage points
it was those precinct captains and those
black captains and there's no reason
under Sun why we can't do this
and believe me you start talking to
people on their doorsteps they're not
talking to you about small government of
big government they're talking about
problems that they face that the
communities face and what we ought to be
doing about who's
it's a very serious problem maybe you
got to spend less time trying to educate
the world on what democracy isn't get
serious about democracy in the United
States which is being which is where
there are serious efforts is all of you
note to curb the ability of folks
especially poor folks Minari folks to
vote and it's serious and we've now got
a Supreme Court in the United States
which has handed sound handed down I
mean the Civil Rights Act is
unconstitutional I mean there are a few
lawyers in the room I used to be one
right how can a Civil Rights Act passed
by the Congress of United States
overwhelmingly with strong bipartisan
support after extensive hearings
how can an extension of the Civil Rights
Act be unconstitutional I don't get it
what is this now we got a new guy in the
Supreme Court trust me he'll be worse
than Scalia my classmate at law school
of course such will be worse than Scalia
I mean that guy's to the right of Marie
Antoinette I'm serious well that's what
happens you know when you don't win the
presidency and here I'm sorry to go on a
great length yeah great that's thank you
going back to building consensus yeah
you know during the Obama
administration's we had one law one
major law and it was passed without a
single Republican vote yeah it was the
health care act eight years with our
laws so the president was forced to to
use orders and directives to make things
work right I'm very afraid that we're
going to end up in the same situation
for at least four years now and my
question is how is it possible to think
of a body that works as internal
diplomats
whoo bridge the gap between Republicans
and Democrats so that we can get
consensus because it's a process as we
all know yeah and it's a it's a
structured process sometimes is that a
wild idea as it is it can the media play
that role and the media is not playing
that role it's playing the the all the
study partisan vote well actually there
are Republicans and Democrats working on
bipartisan issues in the Congress and a
lot you know a lot of legislation passed
in the first two years the Obama
administration just wasn't health care
there's a lot of stuff including an
infrastructure bill which passed pretty
decisively and as and as I say hold on
who's calling who's coming tell him I've
already contributed I love these guys
but Elizabeth Warren and a forget her
name a quite conservative Republican
congresswoman from Tennessee have just
been working on getting people with
hearing problems much less expensive
hearing aids now 20 years ago if you
said to me well you know that's an
important issue I just said hearing aids
now the kidding iron eighties not only
are we having you know I find in class
these days I got to move closer to my
students never had to do that before
kitty now wears hearing aids and I don't
have to tell you what you pay for
hearing aids well there's some new
hearing aid that you can get for 300
bucks not 2000 and and the Tennessee
congresswoman and Elizabeth Warren are
working hard to do something about that
the guy from
Texas Cornyn and who's the Democratic
can't remember is it Chris Murphy no he
no he's from Connecticut I'm just wanted
he and are working on at least a modest
effort to control guns is it Chris with
John Koerner yeah huh really let me say
this to you folks my state has the
toughest gun laws in the country and we
have the lowest homicide rate in the
country I think they're related I think
they're related but these these things I
mean there are people in the Congress
who are looking at opportunities to find
common ground
well Olympia was but we see Olympia was
one of those moderate Republicans who
you know was deeply committed to
universal health care now for a variety
of reasons I think the Democrats badly
mishandled her she could have been a she
could have been a very decisive vote
here in a number of ways and she wanted
to be and without getting into the
details of that I mean but she was the
kind of person that you know I mean I
work with with great Republicans I am
even today bill weld was my successor
now we haven't a practice law together
in fact I supervised him when he was a
young associate in my law firm and he a
now are working hard to convince the new
governor that we ought to finally
connect north and south station by rail
and have a fully integrated regional
rail system in not only eastern
Massachusetts but New England
Wells my Ally on this he and I are
working on mass smoker and North Adams
which is not only a great success we
turn empty factory buildings it's all of
us succeeded each other you know a great
Museum of Contemporary Art but now we're
talking about turning North Adams and
doing a Center for the Arts seriously
you look for common ground you look for
people that you can can work with us on
this kind of thing and it is happening
but you're right we're not hearing much
about it in the press which is covering
this daily gong show at the White House
you know every day but you have to keep
working at that okay I just I think it's
it's so important that if you're in
government that you you do that and I
hope we can yeah go ahead
long-term ism into legislators and
administration's like public debts
Social Security and problems like this
with difficulty but you keep working at
it and trust me if you set the stage for
this
I mean took a long time for us to get
off this highway thing in Massachusetts
and not only to emphasize public
transportation but to do so in a way
which would help revive our older
industrial communities which were in
terrible shape when I first was elected
the mid 70s we had unemployment rates in
in the in the older mills cities the
lols the hay rules the new Bedford's the
Fall River's in the 20s not anymore
holes one of the great model cities why
well a couple of Greeks named Duke
åkesson Tsongas went to work and
convinced people that we should invest
as a quarter of a billion dollars in
state money and Lowell but let me tell
you something Lowell today is a model
for a old industrial community is now
revived and it's doing exceedingly well
and we're doing or trying to do that and
in all of our other older urban
communities still have work to do
long-range yeah but we somehow managed I
think to convince people that this was
an important priority that government
could do it not by itself obviously but
that it was an important part of the the
mix and in point of fact those old mill
cities of coming back in a remarkable
way by the way in case you've missed it
cities are coming back isn't that
amazing
you're coming back when I first got
elected the legislature folks you know
Boston was practically dying and so were
a lot of other cities and
and elsewhere you know it was a the city
was racist it was anti-semitic it was
divided it was angry Boston Harbor was a
sore I mean I could go on and on on not
these days with pretty strong broad
bipartisan support so there are people
in Congress working at this and one of
the things we ought to be doing is
trying to encourage him to do so and I
think we can but it's always a piano
short term long term can you convince
people that that they ought to be
working now on things that is one of the
reasons why infrastructure is so
important it's nothing short term about
infrastructure and it has a profound
effect on how you grow what you know how
where investment goes and all that kind
of stuff um it's critical you can
convince people that a long-term
infrastructure program makes sense and
they'll invest in it it'll have profound
effects maybe one or two more questions
then we'll wrap up yet youth will be
served
go ahead one of the kalos Athenians who
weren't participating actively in the
politics the community you remember
Ethiopia which for those of you don't
speak Greek needless to say as the root
word for idiot the Ortiz was the word he
used right anyway government in public
service and it seems like that has been
you know very much a part of the
American tradition from yeah yeah to
Roosevelt I I think now it's beginning
to decline I like I mean I'm not sure
Reagan exactly was a statesman and at
this point Trump it seems to be like now
we're just outright rejecting it right
with like people like a boy anymore
I don't agree with it I don't agree with
you my students these
days are really hopped up about public
service thanks to Donald Trump
no it's really kind of interesting I've
got kids pouring in my office every day
want to sit down and talk about how they
get into public service I have hundreds
I've been teaching for 27 years I've got
hundreds and hundreds of former students
who are out there doing great stuff one
of them just got elected to Congress in
California his name is Jimmy Gomez who
was Jimmy Gomez the youngest of six in a
family of Mexican immigrants who came to
the United States illegally in the 1970s
got amnesty under the Reagan amnesty
bill in case people have forgotten this
in 1986 they settled in Riverside whose
mayor by the way is also a former
student of mine and a terrific mayor
who's now pairing up religious
congregations with homeless people
rusty Bailey is going to have a
religious organization adopting every
single homeless person representing
anyway back to Gomez
so Goya's ends up in Riverside almost
dies at the age of six because they
don't have health insurance and they
don't get him to the hospital on time
and graduates from high schools working
at Target or something and somehow took
a course at the Riverside Community
College you got to be somebody said to
him you want to enroll here and he did
and then transfer to UCLA and I get him
and of course I teach in California
policy issues some about this kid so I
bring them in have a conversation I say
you interested in politics well if you
haven't been apart no you interested
yeah I'm kind of interested
Jimmy Thomas graduated magna from UCLA
went to the Kennedy School and got a
masters at Harvard went back out to Los
Angeles went to work for the unions went
to work for a member of Congress ran for
the assembly from East Los Angeles got
elected and in the special election to
fill Xavier Becerra vacant seat it was
not
general Gomez won by 20 percentage
points it sounds pretty good to me but
you guys have got to get involved that's
the important thing and I must say to
you that in a crazy kind of way Trump
seems to have stimulated an enormous
interest in at least the kids on
teaching these days on both coasts by
the way in public service but they need
some guy to say these those of us who've
been in the business to take him in hand
and say no I'm Haiti you can do this you
know it's the most open political system
in the world folks I mean what was a
Greek kid in the town of Brookline doing
running for office I don't know you know
I hardly had a big ethnic vote in the
town of Brookline Massachusetts right so
I ran for Town Meeting from our precinct
rang every doorbell stood in front of a
polling place for 13 hours got elected
that's where it all started
you can do the same you can do the same
question what do I think of his what if
I see him I'm gonna tell him to go to
Glacier National Park in a hurry because
in 10 years there won't be any glaciers
there and I'm gonna ask him whether or
not he has any conception of what is
going on it's very interesting and I'll
conclude with this one of the
interesting things that's happened is
that governors States and mayors and
local communities with a lot of help
from the former mayor of New York who
happens to be a native of Medford
Massachusetts whose family couldn't buy
a house in Medford Massachusetts when he
was a kid because he was Jewish they
were Jewish and they had to go through a
straw to get the house that's Mike
bloomer anyway Bloomberg has an
Institute now which he's supporting he's
very committed to doing something about
climate change and that Institute with
you know Jerry Brown and a number of
other governors and and and mayors have
basically said to the world hey don't
pay any attention to that guy
we hope political office and were for
the Paris agreement and we're gonna do
everything we can to implement it kind
of interesting what was the last time
that happened and by the way notice that
while all of this nonsense is going on
in Washington state and local
governments are for the most part out
there doing their jobs and reflecting I
think a lot more of the values that are
represented in a room like this and I
represented in Trump Tower meantime the
business is going south you know so
maybe he'll pay attention to that as
well but you know the look call is gone
I mean I'm sorry I
you know I but I won West Virginia by 12
percentage points and I got a lot of
votes from coal miners but coal is gone
you know and and the private sector is
leaving called
not using coal anymore and this guy in
China whatever you think of his politics
has just announced that they're gonna be
all electric by 2030 2040 you know so I
continue to be fairly optimistic when I
share the same feelings most of us we
have when we wake up in the morning
discover that we've got another tweet
and it's another crazy something oh
sorry anyway it's been great fun being
with you to the young people
particularly I hope I hope you'll get
into this business and get into it
seriously and and encourage your fellow
Greek Americans you've got a great
heritage and and I think a great
responsibility and I hope you'll follow
up on that Thanks
[Applause]